there is nothing to be done  it's only the emotional part  that he  pulls himself together and  he can able to resign  he knows that it's not the  objectively the life of his game but  he did it when he had to do it  and it was an incredible difficult  game for him to be able to  choose an opening go for the  simplification  be ready for  for creating an opportunity be patient  to  to create  that situation where he repeated the  move and there gave an opportunity for  nakamura to go wrong he couldn't have  been aware of all these nuances and  things  he was just ready to fight it out until  two kings i believe yeah and he was  ready and alert  that's great and nakamura resigns  that means  liran finishes second in the candidates  2022.  congratulations to him as well the  winner is yanipan  as we've known definitely  congratulations and wow this is chess we  have happy guys and upset players  in every round